[Music]
they say there are no new ideas in
hollywood
and to that we say good after all why
waste time coming up with a bad new idea
when you can just remake a classic
old good idea if something was a hit
once chances are it'll be a hit again
which is why hollywood is currently
working on another slew of awesome
reboots here's a look at some upcoming
remakes that will get you pumped
little shop of horrors the original 1960
version of little shop of horrors was
directed by roger corman and featured a
brief appearance by a masochistic jack
nicholson
this is gonna hurt you more than it is
oh goody goody here it comes
the film inspired an off-broadway
musical which in turn gave birth to the
1986 movie directed by frank oz
now it looks like tinseltown is opening
up little shop for a third time
deadline calls the new project a fresh
version of the 30 year old frank oz
directed film
but on this go around greg berlanti will
be the one shouting action
if berlanti's name sounds familiar
that's because he's the producer behind
tv hits like riverdale the flash
and supergirl hey if anyone can defeat
audrey 2
it's the maid of might the fly
if you're a horror fan you know the
original fly starring vincent price hit
theaters back in 1958
[Applause]
[Music]
and in 1986 david cronenberg decided to
give the tale its own
grotesque spin casting jeff goldblum and
gina davis
in one of the nastiest monster movies
ever made
now it looks like jd dillard might very
well create his own insect monstrosity
in march 2017 variety reported that the
up and coming director is in talks for
the fly
coming off his critically acclaimed
debut slight dillard told slash film
that if he ends up directing the film
he'll be focusing on the characters
and not the effects saying i think if
you look at a lot of remix and the ones
that may have not been as successful as
others
i think often times the wrong pieces are
remade
white men can't jump in 1992 woody
harrelson and wesley snipes joined
forces in the classic basketball comedy
white men
can't jump written and directed by ron
shelton the film was a major hit
earning over 90 million dollars
worldwide so it's no wonder hollywood is
interested in a remake
with blackish showrunner kenya barris
producing and writing
and if there's one thing we know from
watching blackish it's that he's got
game
does he think he can do better bring it
on bad boy
first blood we all know rambo can
survive in the woods
fight the viet cong and shoot
helicopters with explosive tipped
arrows but can he sing and dance well it
looks like we're about to find out as
the action movie icon is headed to
bollywood starring up and coming actor
tiger shroff
the first blood remake will be titled
rambo and according to entertainment
weekly
the movie will follow the last surviving
member of an elite covert unit of the
indian armed forces who returns home to
find that his land is in the mist of war
filming on rambo has been delayed for
now but they do have a cool poster so
here's hoping it comes out soon
charlie's angels the classic 1970s tv
series charlie's angels was relaunched
as a successful film series in 2000
but sony apparently figures it's been
long enough for yet another try
as a new big screen version is
reportedly set for a 2019 release
nobody has actually been cast in it yet
but elizabeth banks is set to direct
and kristen stewart and lupita nyong'o
are rumored to be in the running for
roles
the cannonball run despite being
critically panned
1981's cannonball run became a cult hit
spawning a sequel thanks to a massive
all-star cast that included everyone
from burt reynolds and roger moore to
sammy davis jr and jackie chan
now it looks like the racers are revving
up their engines again
as universal is bringing the cannonball
run back to theaters
according to deadline thomas lennon and
robert bengarant of knight to the museum
fame might write the script
while dodgeball director ross and
thurber is attached as well
here's hoping they somehow tie captain
chaos into the marvel cinematic universe
[Music]
alien nation the 1988 film alien nation
was a big enough hit that it spawned a
spin-off tv series
so it makes sense that fox might want to
do a remake however according to
director jeff nichols his upcoming
remake of alien nation
isn't a remake at all telling screen
crush it doesn't really have anything to
do with the original
turns out nichols and fox decided to
slap the alien nation label on a totally
unrelated project the director was
developing
because why not we don't know what the
story is about
but at least the fans know what it's not
about so that's something
right flash gordon in 2015
it was announced that matthew vaughn the
guy behind kick-ass
x-men first class and both kingsman
films would be remaking flash gordon
there's just one problem though
guardians of the galaxy
vonn told collider the only problem with
flash gordon
is guardians kind of stole what i would
have liked to have done with it
as a result the upcoming flash gordon
film has been delayed while vaughn tries
to figure out how to do it
good luck matt
[Music]
nosferatu before twilight before blade
there was nosferatu the first
full-length vampire movie starred max
schreck
as the rat like count orlock an undead
demon who sent
audiences into hysterics in 1922. nearly
a century later
the film is set to be remade by the
witch director robert eggers
starring the witch actress anya taylor
joy and
famed creature specialist doug jones as
the vampire
just when the film will go into
production is up in the air but we can't
wait to see it when it finally arrives
pet cemetery according to variety
paramount is planning to remake the
classic stephen king story pet cemetery
with starry eyes directors kevin kolsch
and dennis widmeyer set to direct
no word yet on who is going to star in
it but given the spotty track record of
recent king adaptations
here's hoping this one is more like it
and less like the dark tower
yet another king remake it's really
gonna happen isn't it oh
yes it is run
it won a special oscar for its visual
effects but in the four decades since
logan's run's release
the movie has been largely forgotten by
mainstream audiences
directed by michael anderson this sci-fi
film was set in a futuristic society
where people are executed once they
reach their 30th birthday
well no one has to die at 30 you could
live
it's a sci-fi premise that's begging for
a modern take
and will soon get a remake courtesy of
simon kinberg who wrote x-men days of
future past
and x-men apocalypse no word on who will
star
but according to deadline they may make
the lead a woman this time around
so it should be interesting to see what
direction they had with it
highlander among immortal swordsmen
there can be
only one but if we're talking about
movies about immortal swordsmen
well that's a totally different story
there have been multiple live-action
highlander movies
a couple of tv series and a cartoon and
now it looks like lion's gate is finally
moving forward with the long-awaited
remake of the 1986 cult classic
with john wick director chad stahlski
attached and hey
no matter what happens it's guaranteed
to be better than highlander 2
fantastic voyage it's one of those
science fiction classics that's largely
been forgotten by modern day audiences
starring raquel welch and donald
pleasance the 1966 hit fantastic voyage
follows a group of scientists who shrink
down to microscopic size
climb inside a miniature submarine and
set sail inside a comatose patient
hoping to save him from a brain clot
it's a pretty cool premise
one that's just perfect for a remake and
fortunately for sci-fi fans
guillermo del toro is the man who will
bring this tiny story to the big screen
originally the movie was supposed to hit
theaters in 2019
but production was paused so that del
toro could focus on promoting the shape
of water
things appear to be back on track now
though so assuming this really is the
oscar winner's next project
this sci-fi adventure will definitely be
worth the wait
flight of the navigator tron wasn't the
only cult sci-fi hit disney released in
the 80s they also put out flight of the
navigator which was about a kid who is
abducted by aliens and implanted with
all sorts of secret knowledge that the
government desperately wants their hands
on
now lionsgate and the henson company are
teaming up for a new adaptation
and after briefly considering colin
trevaro in 2012
they're hiring joe henderson the
showrunner behind lucifer to pen the
screenplay
and with the henson company's
involvement we've got our fingers
crossed that we might get to see
a few cool puppets you're very lucky
slave
only the emperor can drink your essence
okay maybe not but hopefully we'll at
least get paul reuben's back as the
wisecracking computer
don't forget to feed fusion special
thoughts lettuce cheese pickles
sesame seeds
cleopatra jones while not as famous as
pam greer
tamara dobson left her mark on the
blaxploitation genre with cleopatra
jones
a kick-ass 1973 film about a woman who
works as a supermodel as a cover for her
real job
spying for the u.s government it's a
pretty fun premise and perfect for a
remake
and that's why warner brothers has hired
misha green
creator of the wgn show underground to
pin a script and create what deadline
calls
the female answer to james bond sounds
promising west side story
while it might not begin tonight
production on a brand new west side
story will start in the very near future
this remake of the 1961 classic will be
directed by steven spielberg
making his first musical according to
the hollywood reporter
spielberg has been wanting to direct
this film for decades
and now he's teaming up with
screenwriter tony kushner to make his
dream come true
spielberg and kushner previously worked
together on lincoln and munich
and as kushner has won an emmy a tony
and the pulitzer
we can safely assume the script is in
capable hands as for the cast
the filmmaker sent out a casting call in
january 2018
searching for actors ages 15 to 25 to
play the lead parts of tony maria
anita and bernardo and thankfully unlike
the original film
spielberg plans on casting the lead
latino characters with
actual latino actors which is cool
48 hours hot off saturday night live
eddie murphy made his feature film debut
with 48 hours
which basically created the buddy cop
genre while becoming a box office smash
the action comedy is widely considered
an 80s classic
but now it's getting a 21st century spin
jared carmichael is set to star
and co-write the project while brothers
josh and ben saftey
who previously directed the critically
acclaimed films heaven knows what and
good time
will be behind the cameras rabbit
when it comes to body horror it doesn't
get any better
or bloodier than the work of david
cronenberg though most of his films are
famous
back when he was still rising through
the ranks he directed the forgotten 1977
cult flick
rabbid which presaged the whole zombie
plague strain of films
and now it's going to be remade by jen
and sylvia soska
known to horror fans as the twisted
twins the duo was set to begin
filming the rabid remake in april 2018
with what andy indiewire calls a
modern and relevant spin from the
woman's perspective
we sure can't wait thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too you